joining us now is the party's co-leader
Jonathan Bartley thanks very much clang
on the pranky this morning and before we
get to your offer I just want to get
your reaction to Jeremy Corbyn at that
TV debate last night saying that if
there was a second referendum he would
adopt a neutral position honestly I
think people will look at that debate
last night I think is this the best
we've got you know you got someone a
prime minister who appears to be a
racist and a liar you've got a leader of
the Opposition whose expertise used to
be in fence city not just on this issue
but on whole series of issues across the
manifesto and the Liberal Democrats
trying to occupy the center ground by
riding roughshod over democracy hang on
a minute so why are you doing an
alliance with the Lib Dems and if you
think they want to rut ride roughshod
over democracy that's a pretty punchy
plane why they're not going to form the
government let's be honest about that we
all know that's not going to happen they
are a remaining party and on that
particular issue we agree with them and
we think the best way of moving forward
as a country is having the biggest block
of romaine parties in the next
parliament I mean it might not be a Tory
majority it might still be a hung
parliament and that would give us undue
influence in order to get that people's
vote and campaign to remain in the
European Union so basic remaining in the
EU trumps everything even if you think
they're riding roughshod over democritus
know a people's vote is the way forward
is the route because we need to think
about also uniting the country learn to
disagree well but we are always and have
always been passionately remain errs
because we believe that's one of the
best ways of tackling the climate
emergency it's about protecting the
environmental protections that we run in
but the environmental rights but also
working with our neighbors
we've also signed up to the Paris
agreement more closely and let's talk a
little bit about and your offer on
climate change shall we and use because
you say you want to spend a hundred
billion pounds every year tackling what
you define as the climate emergency I
must look quite fun being part of
opposition you can just promise what you
want can't you hundred billion pounds a
year well no I mean look look at you
know you're just having a discussion
about where you get the money from and
we were saying that you know borrowing
is probably the most effective way you
can raise money you can do tax changes
but there's another way which didn't
really come up and that's making the
right choices about where you save now
all the other parties are going to go
ahead with HST
right labour have actually said
now I think it's going to go out to 250
billion pounds because they can extend
it to Scotland this is an
environmentally destructive project now
that is two and a half years of our
ten-year program two hundred fifty
billion pounds they're all going ahead
with trident renewal you know that's
going to be another hundred billion down
so there's another year now you know
we're not just saying you need to borrow
every single penny or indeed raise taxes
what we're saying is make the right
choices make the right environmental
choices let's transform let's
restructure the economy I just will talk
a little bit more about the economics of
this though because I think people will
have concerns about these really big
ticket spending items and just look at
the IFS for example they believe that
your proposals will take borrowing to
140 billion pounds that's six percent of
GDP the highest level since the global
crash it would double the limits set by
that you use growth and stability pact I
mean is that really responsible we've no
disparate times call for desperate
measures and we know that we face a
climate emergency we know we're going to
have to make this investment but let's
look at it historically you can see
results you know two new deals you can
see the Marshall Plan you can see what
happened after the Second World War and
you know these things when you want a
transformation of the economy when you
know you have to make it you need to
make you think it's comparable then the
climate emergency to the world it's an
existential threat I mean okay 55
million people died in the Second World
War the threat of the climate emergency
is much much bigger than that you know
there is no real bigger threat except of
course nuclear weapons and now okay so
let's have a look at some of the other
policies in your manifesto in a bit more
detail we know of course you want to
discourage flying we know that there is
clearly an environmental impact of
flying so you want to make domestic
flights 20% more expensive by losing the
v80 exemption and a frequent flier levy
for people who take more than one fly
year you're not a bit worried though
that this just gonna punish people who
can't afford it so you're wealthy enough
to visit your family abroad you can do
it as much as you want but if you can't
afford it sorry tough luck we know we
have to do is replace up to the real
cost of flying which isn't just the
financial cost of the fly levy it's the
massive massive environmental cost we're
the only party that's saying you know
what a snake expert airport expansion
right off the table now of course we
have to set it at a rate that's going to
work we know that 70% of the flights are
taken by just 15% of the people there is
a binge line mentality amongst
for primarily the super originally City
Airport the average wage as someone
comes through there is about 120,000
pounds a year so why don't we cap it and
rather than make it that money because I
super-rich can still have flies watch
they walk well we feel that they need to
pay their way and we need to set it at a
rate you know it will increase
exponentially so you know the first
flight would be free the second flight
will go up a little bit more a third
flight a little bit more than that and
then it'll go up and up and up in much
greater numbers so we do need to clamp
down and restrict that demand and
obviously needs to be piloted and set at
a level where it is going to work and
restrict that super rich how much
responsibility is our on us as
individuals to do more and you've said
that you've recently configured for
example I mean do you have any clip
noriko friendly guilty pleasures don't
stop thank you I mean the big thing
we're saying is that it's got to be
political change you know I Drive a
petrol car but the reason I do is
because I have a son who's a wheelchair
user our local station isn't accessible
you can't get on any buses and if you
get on the tube at brixton you can't get
off anywhere you know because the tube
stations aren't accessible we need to
make it possible for people to make the
right choices and just reducing it down
to the personal level is not going to
provide anywhere near the amount of
change that we need it has to be big big
big change from the top transitioning
every sector of the economy so we're
cutting fares
so we're electrifying all the rails
we're putting on new bus routes and
we're making it easy for people to leave
their cars behind and get decent public
transport that works for everybody and
well we've got I'm interested to know
about your opinion on the story that's
been in the media a lot recently which
is and that of Prince Andrew and his
decision of course give her interview on
his friendship with a convicted sex
offender Jeffrey Epstein
now Jeremy Corbyn said this week that
the monarchy needed in his words a bit
of improvement what's your take well I
guess Sean said last week when she was
here and you know she was quite bold
when everyone was not saying anything
she stood out and said yet questions
need to be answered I think that there
are still questions that are unanswered
I don't think just Andrew withdrawing
from public life is a solution but the
point here is the victims that are at
the center of this the survivors of
abuse no one should be above the
questions and these questions need to be
put and this is no substitute no
alternative and then just finally I read
a recent interviewed over the Metro and
that quote jumped out to me you said I
didn't behave that well as a young
person growing up I was quite wild as a
team do you want to share a bit more of
what you're up to
well I've always been a musician played
in bands and I mean there's that when I
do gigs are still playing a band okay
this is not a not word-for-word correct
but my frontman when he gets up on stage
he has to introduce Who I am and he says
you know there's always a choice for
Jonathan between politics and the career
in music and when he found out how much
sex and drugs there were in politics
Jeff it's not true at all
I've always been guided by my passion to
change the world and that's what that's
what drives me I was maybe I were
playing the world side a bit gave up the
sex and drugs and thank you very much
for being on the program today Jonathan
Bartley there